[Music]
they came to remind the world that in
the United States the fight for racial
equality is still far from Over
retracing the footsteps of those who
marched in 1963.
[Music]
60 years ago 250 000 people led by the
young Reverend Martin Luther King Jr
linked arms raised their voices and
heard a King's speech about his dream
for equality
on Saturday the thousands who marched
say King's dream is still unfulfilled
prognosis feels grim and there are some
things that have changed but today's
March in commemoration just emphasizes
how much still needs to be done I've
noticed that even when I work maybe
somebody of another color would get paid
more money than I do and even though I
might even have more education in the
U.S the African-American poverty rate is
more than double that of white Americans
police brutality targeting blacks
remains an ongoing problem and some
conservative states have moved to ban
the teaching of African-American studies
in school there will be other times
Martin Luther King Jr's eldest son
delivered an updated rallying cry dad
would probably say now is the damn we
must preserve protect and expand
democracy we must ensure that voting
rights is protected for all people we
must ensure that our women and children
are treated fairly we must end gun
violence
this March spoke for a greater variety
of groups with protesters calling for
protecting lgbtq and Asian American
rights and while in 1963 only one woman
spoke to the crowd today many took the
podium
have you
have yours
all across the nation we
are going to be
a great generation
the Marchers say each step is another
toward progress but the target of true
equality remains distant
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Washington
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera